[Music]  in October 1989 43 women around the  world gave birth none of these women had  been pregnant when the day first began  how much do you want for it  I have adopted six children  gifted with abilities far beyond the  ordinary I give you the Umbrella Academy  [Music]  does anyone wish to speak it was a  monster everything about our family is  insane  it always had  [Music]  is that my skirt oh yeah this it's very  breezy on the bits mrs. C nothing's  changed I jumped forward and got stuck  in the future do you know what I found  absolutely nothing when's it supposed to  happen in eight days there was someone  out there who's trying to stop me from  preventing the apocalypse we need the  full force of the academy bingo  yay sisters yay sisters  [Music]  get up we're going we're save the world  oh is that all  you  you